hey 42 here now before we begin and I
really shouldn't have to say this but
please don't murder anyone
this video is no more than a Fort
exercise and not a guide colloquially a
perfect crime is any crime that can be
committed without there being any chance
of the perpetrator ever being caught by
the authorities or their identity being
revealed the perfect crime is entirely
unsolvable even to the world's best
detective any type of crime can be a
perfect crime such as a robbery or fraud
what today I'll focus on murder because
well it's the most interesting and
typically the most difficult crime to
get away with so theoretically in
today's world could you commit murder
and get away with it and furthermore
ensure that there is no possible way
that you could ever ever be caught the
first and most important thing of any
budding criminal can do to achieve the
perfect crime is to put as much distance
between himself and the crime as
possible and when I say distance I don't
mean physical increasing that helps sure
but what's much more important is to
increase the number of unrelated people
between you under the victim and when I
say unrelated that includes the victim
himself if we're talking about murder
then you would need to somehow get
someone you don't know to murder someone
else you also don't know this setup
would give the police the least
ammunition to follow up leads with
family friends and acquaintances and to
think of potential motives you may have
had which are two of the strongest tools
detectives have today to converge on a
suspect but this of course begs the
obvious question if you don't know the
victim then why would you want to kill
them in the first place unless you're
pure cold blooded psychopath attempting
to kill someone you know will always
leave some kind of telling trail and
possibly this means at least in that
scenario the perfect crime
could not exist but let's explore
further before jumping to vast
conclusions these days of course
everything you do every day is tracked
your phone can be triangulated in real
time and smartphone store a record of
your precise movements and any journeys
you take CCTV follows you everywhere
with face recognition fast becoming a
new normal and many modern cars with
infotainment systems and GPS track and
record the owners journey just after
midnight on the 19th of April 2019 in an
extremely remote location in Anglesey
Wales Gerald's Kuragin was shot and
killed with a crossbow bombs in a
completely random act of psychopathic
violence the murderous heavy wall was
only caught because his wife's land
rover discovery had automatically and
silently recorded his journey to the
murder site and saved it to the clown
with all these modern crime-fighting
technologies and techniques considered
according to the world's leading
criminologists the perfect crime cannot
exist and for that we should all be
thankful perhaps it did fifty years ago
but forensics DNA analysis psychological
profiling and the extreme proliferation
of modern technology and video
surveillance has now eradicated any
opportunity to ensure any crime is
entirely untraceable at least in most
developed countries and before you start
shouting at me but what if I paid
someone on the dark web to do it with
crypto currencies well firstly those are
really not as untraceable as is commonly
believed in fact Bitcoin and similar
technologies work by being 100%
transparent and decentralized which
makes hiding your criminal transaction
almost impossible and the dark web has
been heavily infiltrated and tracked by
the FBI for over a decade and secondly I
think you need to talk to someone
criminologists say the closest thing to
the
perfect crime today would be to murder
someone completely random without any
premeditation and don't tell anyone
obviously the perpetrator must also have
a completely clean criminal record but
most importantly of all it should be
done in a crowded public place surprised
well this is because it almost entirely
negates the opportunity for DNA evidence
to be effective or admissible in court
I've talked about why this is it much
more depth in a previous video which
I'll link to in a description but
basically the more people around you at
the time of the murder
the more random people's DNA will be
present at the crime scene which dilutes
and confuses any DNA sample left by the
actual killer
it would allow his DNA to hide in plain
sight
whereas if the murder is committed in a
private location there could just be two
DNA samples found at the scene the
victims and the killers which makes the
job considerably easier for forensics
and the police and no matter how much
protective apparel one may wear it's
almost impossible to not leave some
minut trace of one's DNA at a crime
scene what if I told you that perhaps
the perfect crime
does still exist yes even today there
are any very small and limited number of
ways that you could theoretically murder
someone and get away scot-free the
problem is you're going to have to go to
some really really specific places
firstly you could venture into the zone
of death if you could coerce your victim
to this positively delightful sounding
spot you could commit the perfect crime
note that if you were to kidnap him and
bring him here what I'm about to say is
a completely null and void because you
can then be charged with kidnapping
committed before you entered the zone
within the beautiful Yellowstone
National Park on the border between
Idaho Wyoming lies a 50 square meter
rectum
no to locals as the zone of death why
well according to the United States
Constitution anyone who is charged with
a crime in federal land which
Yellowstone is must be trailed by a jury
of his peers from the federal district
and state in which the crime was
committed the issue is that the district
boundary lines of Yellowstone overlap in
two neighboring states why is that an
issue let me explain
so the killer would be taken to
Yellowstone's district court which is
located in Cheyenne but according to
article 3 section 2 of the Constitution
that states a trial shall be held in the
state where the said crimes have been
committed the killer could legally
Monday that the trial take place in
Idaho so the defendant would be taken to
Idaho for his trial but it's also in the
Constitution that a jury has to be from
the state under the district where the
crime was committed which means under US
constitutional law the entire jury has
to come from within the zone of death
because it's both in the state of Idaho
but within the district where the crime
was committed the District of
Yellowstone but the crucial issue here
which gives this legal loophole its
weight is that this specific area has a
population of zero so a jury could not
be called from within the zone of death
and therefore the trial could not
legally go ahead even if the police were
there to witnessed a murder happen or
even if they filmed it the police would
literally have no other choice but to
let the perpetrator walk away a free man
laws and borders are notoriously complex
and so it's entirely possible there
exists another legal loophole maybe also
in the US but maybe elsewhere that would
allow ones who kill with impunity and it
just so happens that nobody has worked
out what it is yet or where it is
unless they have and we don't know about
it there is however another way that is
commonly espoused who provides such a
legal loophole and allows for the
perfect crime I'm talking about the
mysterious international waters under
United Nations international law 12
nautical miles from the coastline of
each country is considered to be that
nation's territorial waters wherein the
full walls of that country still apply
but beyond that lies so-called
international waters which are legally
speaking not owned by any nation
this is no-man's land many Hollywood
films have popularized the idea that
because nobody owns this vast watery
expanse of the planet you could
technically drive a boat out into open
ocean murder a fellow passenger toss
them overboard and then come back to
land havin not actually broken any
territorial laws and therefore you would
not be arrested
the theory was sort of tested on New
Year's Eve in 2017 when a group of New
Zealanders constructed a mountain of
sand in the middle of the coastal inlets
then placed a picnic table on it and
cracked open a few beers they were
attempting to circumvent a local ban on
drinking alcohol on New Year's Eve by
claiming that they were in international
waters the police pointed out the fact
that they were not in international
waters they were actually in the middle
of an estuary and therefore fully
subject to the laws of the state however
the police found their attempt to drink
so hilariously commendable they let them
off the hook but what is the truth about
international waters are there really no
laws out there well thankfully this old
and dying myth is absolute total rubbish
every ship has to be registered by a
country and is subject to the laws of
that country a hugely disproportionate
amount of the world's vessels are
registered in Panama
because it offers some of the most lacks
laws and regulations but if you choose
to not register your ship and not fly
any flag under international law your
vessel will be considered a pirate ship
and the target of the navies of the most
powerful countries on earth basically
all of NATO because you're unidentified
shape will fall under universal
jurisdiction which means any nation
state can intervene your vessel and
prosecute you in their country if they
find you guilty of committing crimes
against international laws this includes
but is not limited to piracy torture
slavery and illegal broadcasting but
there is yes another way that you could
get into trouble for your high seas
murder the passive person principle this
is another doctrine of international law
which states that anyone can be
convicted of a crime by a nation when it
is perpetrated against one of its
citizens within international waters or
elsewhere where local or state level
jurisdiction does not apply so if the
unlucky victim that you choose to take
on your boat and murder in the middle of
the ocean is a US citizen for example it
doesn't matter that you aren't on
American soil or you aren't an American
citizen under the passive person
principle you have just committed a
crime against the United States and they
are well within their rights to hunt you
down arrest and prosecute you in America
so to put it bluntly you cannot commit a
perfect crime in international waters
obviously the point of perfect crimes is
that we seldom know they ever happens so
who knows how many ostensibly perfect
crimes have been committed throughout
history but perhaps the closest anyone
has ever come to committing the perfect
crime that we actually know about was in
Germany in 2009 when 6.8 million dollars
worth of jewelry was stolen from the
grand calf house there west
it's department store three mask
criminals were caught on CCTV and one of
them left DNA at the scene which
forensics were able to successfully
match against the police database the
issue was the DNA belonged to an
identical twin
the police tracked down and arrested
both of the identical twins Hasan and
Abbas the issue is that the only solid
evidence the police had to prove one of
them perpetrated the robbery was DNA
evidence of identical twins share 99.99%
of the same DNA with current technology
it is impossible to differentiate
between two twins based on the 0.01% of
DNA that does differ
thus the police could not beyond
reasonable doubt determine which of the
twins was guilty and they therefore had
no option but to let both walk away
three men the twins may not have
intended to commit what was reasonably
close to a perfect crime but that they
did thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video then please consider
supporting me on patreon because it
really helps me to continue to make
these videos the links in the
description below
also if you want to get your hands on a
first edition signed copy of my new book
stick a fork in it a thousand years of
bizarre history from Britain and beyond
you can pre-order your copy at unbound
publishing the links in the description
thank you